I understand that even at twice the  speed of light your journey will take 15  years that's right we'll be traveling so  fast our spacecraft will arrive at the  planet before the transmission of this  interview does how do you prepare for  this one-way mission knowing you will  never return to Earth Iowa crew a very  skilled and focused individuals we all  have a deep desire to explore and  frankly we also have a few attachments  here on earth you weren't always alone  I am told you where once then yes that's  right years ago but then your wife  turned up missing Monday yes ma'am and I  went looking for I searched for day and  night